so are you okay
hello
hello sir
I might have a single one over here
sir is your foot on the break there
Hey sir are you okay
foreign
excuse me sir are you okay
I think it's trying to vehicle off okay
[Music]
it's on the vehicle officer
huh yeah I'm trying to turn the freaking
car off
I'm back so I can put
all right do me a favor Step Up
all right yeah
he was like oh terrible all right have a
seat over there step over here come on
take a seat
have a seat what's going on sir are you
okay
you're not okay when I saw you you were
outside of the vehicle vehicle in the
car yeah
car still in Drive
what's going on tonight
you had loads of drink huh have you had
something to drink tonight no I'm just
waiting um he's trying to go home okay
do you have your license on you huh is
your license in the vehicle
okay
you said it's in his wallet
where you coming from
huh where you coming from
what's your name
I'm good man where are you coming from
tonight
a friend's house
okay
I live right down the street okay
where's your where's your driver's
license sir
[Music]
it's in the car on camera I don't know
where it is fine just keep your hands on
your pockets for me okay
where are you coming from
I was at a friend's house you're at a
friend's house doing what huh what were
you doing I was hanging out with a
friend you're hanging out with friends
okay you realize when I saw you you were
passed out head out of the window
throw up next to you on the ground
you passed out
while driving
get your hands out of your pockets
please
thank you
let's go ahead and take a seat for now
foreign
all right
rubble's you coming
huh
okay just a second okay
yeah yeah
you work for the Sheriff's Office
qualify to route 20.
good
can you whip anyone over here please
how long have you worked over there for
three years
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
on that person
your duty weapon is not on you or in the
vehicle
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cannot afford to hire a lawyer won't be
acquaintance represent you at County
expense before any questions if you
would need to give you a right to remain
silent later wish to stop answering
questions no further questions will be
asked do you understand each part of it
as I explained them to you
having a right to mind you will just
talk to me now
okay but based on my training experience
we're passed out behind the wheel
because for all the people they're all
up outside of the car it's a profound
order of alcohol
America nearby okay and your bloodshot
water guys
I'm gonna afford you this time to
complete a series of field at sobriety
exercises
is that something you wish to do
no
okay
do my favorite one stand up for me
turn around
[Music]
here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
for a period of one year for the first
refusal and a period of 18 months if it
is previously suspended for refused
it'll submit to a test of your breath
urine or blood
furthermore of your reviews to submit to
this chemical test of your breath and
your driving privilege has been
previously suspended for a prior
so are you paying attention yeah okay
for fire refusal to submit to a lawful
test of your breath urine or blood you
come in and miss me during addition to
any other penalties for Jesus to submit
to any chemical tests of your breath
upon the request of the law enforcement
officer shall be admissible into court
in any criminal proceedings
okay
yeah
are you going to submit to a test no
thank you
[Music]
I just need to know for our um so you
have any weapons or anything in the
clouds yeah
[Music]
okay I will
come on
foreign
[Applause]